[Music]
[Applause]
well, the preparation of the burial of the
Salina is carried out throughout the year, it is
a constant work,
each gardening group has a name of
a God from Roman or Greek mythology
Apollo empty Palace
each group, which is 23  It has about 40,000
toys so Well, it multiplies more
than a million toys, much more than a
million toys. I
inherited the position 17 years ago from a
person who, well, left the position and they
had to look for someone else who was
big to fill the suit and  I am very
big because, as I said before, no one
gives you instructions on how to make a
pet sardine. I think that in order for a pet to be
a good pet, you have to not
have any shame, also be a
little fun, not be ashamed, dance,
jump a little, be around.  that the public
asks you because when people see me, above
all they demand attention by shouting at me
sardines sardine or they say to me on Saturday we
will burn you or drink a photo or something like that
because when they told me that they
told me we want you to be Mrs. sardine
literally because I cried I
Tears came because this is an honor
The testament of the tardina is always
a fun text acid ironic in tone
Well satire that touches on current issues
[Music]
in Murcia has a population of
approximately 450,000 inhabitants and on Saturday
Murcia doubles its population  but the
hotels are
100% occupied in the apartments because people
come from all over the world to the
burial of the sardine
[Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
the strongest emotion when we burn the
catafalque  Well, it is a mixture of joy
and sadness, sadness because
the parties and joys of Saturday
night are over, your entire team of gardeners,
my family too, in the
end We are all gardeners, in the end
this is also born from, as we say, a
group of students.  They wanted to
share that joy and little by little
that joy has transformed into
something huge and one of the
most fun parties in the world
[Music]